according to judaism who is god
it's
difficult because judaism like any
tradition
that is thousands of years old and
encompasses so many different lands and
languages and thinkers
it doesn't give a single answer to even
simple questions and to large questions
it certainly doesn't give a single
answer although judaism was responsible
for introducing the monotheistic idea to
the world it doesn't mean that it's one
idea
so if you take maimonides the greatest
sage
in the jewish tradition um medieval
philosopher
he would say that god is an omnipotent
benevolent intangible
unimaginable god in fact he said you
can't say what god is only what god is
not
because you have to emphasize
could talk more about that but basically
you have to emphasize the unknowability
of god
you have a modern philosopher like
heschel who says that god is a god of
pathos a god of deep feeling which
probably would make maimonides shiver if
he heard such a description and
if you look in the bible god is always
regretting or having human emotions
so there are so many different kinds of
depictions and ideas
and there is this tremendous tension
between transcendence and imminence that
is
in the jewish tradition god god is
exquisitely close god is imminent
in the talmud's words god is as close as
your mouth is to your ear
um in other words whatever you say god
hears it and yet at the same time god is
unfathomably distant
sometimes when i speak to high schoolers
i will say in the jewish tradition
think of it this way
when you were two years old you had no
idea what it was to be a 15 year old not
only did you not know but you didn't
know what you didn't know
we conceive of god as being
more the distance between god and human
beings is far greater than the distance
between a two-year-old and a
fifteen-year-old
so when we speak about god we have to
acknowledge how limited we really are
so okay you laid out a lot of
fascinating things on the table so one
the nobility of god
then this idea of deep feeling
which
again can can god be
operating the space of feelings too so
not just the mouth and the ear of the
senses can uh
god be known
can god be felt
by
this three-year-old in the analogy
uh versus the the teenager so i will
take refuge in a beautiful phrase by
from martin buber another jewish
theologian he said god cannot be
expressed god can only be addressed
in other words you can speak to god you
can feel a sense of god but can you
begin to comprehend or know god no
josef cosby i'm pulling in a couple of
uh early jewish philosophers he said to
know god i would have to be god
but can we get close is it useful or is
it a distraction to
visualize things to embody
to create to the uh to attach to the
stories some kind of visualizations in
our mind
uh for example gender he versus she
things like this or old man in the sky
kind of feeling
so it's almost inevitable but i think
ultimately you try to transcend it
this was uh this was the great you know
we just read this actually in synagogue
the story of the golden calf
and the
the story is that human beings found it
impossible
to not have a visualization
because they had just come from egypt
and in pay in the world of of uh pagan
worship everything is it's not that
pagans thought that idol was actually
god but it represented visually what god
was and along comes
this idea that god is actually not
capable of being visualized which is
very difficult and it stretches the
bounds of human comprehension maybe even
breaks them
so would you say the the proper way to
operate
as a human in relation to god is
humility and that you're screwed you're
not able to basically know anything
almost anything
well the reason that you're the
salvation of this is
that you can't
that you can't i was going to say the
reason you're not screwed but then i
thought somebody might be upset at a
rabbi saying that so i'm so i didn't say
it and have not said it yes um but but
the uh
the the reason you're not is
that you don't have to have a
comprehension of god you have to have a
relationship to god
and those are not the same i mean to
draw an uh uh
an analogy that is not far from perfect
as most analogies are but this one
especially
you have relationships with people who
are mysteries to you your mysteries
you're a mystery to yourself um
you can live and love somebody for 50
years and they can say something that
surprises you because ultimately we are
trapped in here
and when a child first says i
we call that individuation but what that
really means
is i i now know that i am cut off from
the minds of all other
children and all other people
and
so you have with god a more intimate
relationship because you can believe
that god is
you are known by god and you have a
relationship to god despite the fact
that you can't know god just as you
can't know others
and some would say to have a good
relationship you want to be constantly
surprised
right you don't want to know the things
well the world yes the world that god
created is constantly surprising but and
by the way the the the caveat to this
you know when i you i had all these
debates with christopher hitchens and he
would always say that god is a greater
tyrant than north korea because it
continues after your death and the idea
of being known by god is after all
frightening if you think god knows what
i think and so on um if your image of
god is unloving
you